The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Review
model analysis.
I figured most-- I figured lots
of students have had questions
and we could use a
little practice on this.
So that's what
we're going to do.
AUDIENCE: Solving the q thing?
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: Solving
the q function?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
solving the whole thing.
So but let's start.
I'd still start with
the usual concepts.
I haven't even erased
what we had last time.
But this is what the
students in the last group
said about key
concepts for the week.
If you want to add
something to it, speak up.
But modal analysis, multi-degree
of freedom, transfer functions,
and then model analysis--
more specifically,
response to initial conditions,
response to steady state
harmonic inputs.
Anything else that was
significant, conceptual,
and new in the last week?
Add to that.
And then the second
thing, what are
issues that are muddy for you?
Not quite clear, things you
want to learn more about,
have questions about.
Last class.
was more on transfer functions
for multi-degree of freedom
systems and solving
initial condition problems
is what one student
was interested in about
from using modal analysis.
But do any of you have
questions about things
that you want to practiced on?
AUDIENCE: So I understand
how to get the new mass
and spring whatever
matricies for the q system,
so I can set it up as the
mq bq kq, but from there,
I don't know how to go
back and solve for x,
or I don't know
how to solve for x.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we'll go through that.
We're going to run through
a complete modal analysis
today, all the steps that you
need to do to make it happen.
So anything else that you've
got a question about that I
might be able to get to?
OK, let's get rolling.
This will take a little while.
So problem for the day is,
if you recall last time,
we had this demo of
this double pendulum.
But now we're going to
take that double pendulum
and make the masses unequal.
So well, the masses
are equal here,
but they could be
unequal-- M1, M2,
they're each half a kilogram.
But we're changing the lengths
a little bit, 1.1 for L1
and 1.0 meters for L2.
So slightly different
lengths, and that'll
make this system not symmetric
so it won't have 1, 1
and 1 minus 1 mode shapes.
A little weak spring in
the middle, possibility
of having some dashpot here
connected to a non-moving wall,
another dashpot here.
And the possibility
of having harmonic
excitations-- F1 on this
one, F2 on that one.
The whole system's
been linearized.
The equations in
motion look something
like this, mass damping
matrix, stiffness matrix.
Of course, it has
gravity terms in it
as well as the spring terms.
And it's been linearized.
This equation in motion, is it
a force equation or a moment
equation?
Are they force or
moment or both?
We can have mixed
ones like the cart.
Problem with the pendulum
has one force equation
and one equation
with units of torque,
this one has units of what?
AUDIENCE: Torque.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is moments about point
A and moments about point B
and give you the two equations.
So this is a torque equation.
So you need to look and see if
things inside here make sense.
So the MGL, the non-linear
equation, the restoring torque,
is MGL sine theta.
Linearized, it's just theta.
So MGL 1 theta is the
torque on the first mass.
M2 GL 2 theta is the torque on
the second mass, and so forth.
And K1 L1 squared,
why the L1 squared?
This term here gets multiplied
by theta 1, so what is that?
What's K1 L1 squared theta 1?
What kind of a
torque-- what is that?
Does it make sense?
Are its units correct?
So first of all, what's
K1 L1 times theta?
AUDIENCE: Force.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's a force.
What's L1 times theta?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Physically,
that is what?
AUDIENCE: Distance.
PROFESSOR: That's the distance
that that thing moves, right?
And a displacement
times a spring constant
gives you a force, and then
that force times a moment arm
gives you a torque.
So it makes sense.
OK, so L1 squared theta 1
is the torque about point A
caused by a
displacement theta 1,
assuming this one
is 0 when you do it.
That's the torque caused by a
displacement of theta 1 only.
OK, all right.
So that's our equations
of motion linearized.
This is the mass matrix.
This is the stiffness
matrix that you
would get if you go into there
and substitute in these values.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The
matrix on the right
would be to one of these
[INAUDIBLE] on the bottom?
PROFESSOR: This one here?
This is a two by two matrix.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: And it has to be.
It's a two degree
freedom system.
This is K11, the K11 term.
This is the K12 term, the
K21 term, and the K2 term.
AUDIENCE: So there's
a space between--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it got
a little squeezed here.
This space, there's an
M2GL2-- and that shouldn't
be squared-- plus KL2 squared.
AUDIENCE: Plus [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: All
right, pretty sure
that's what it out to read like.
MGL2 KL2 squared.
And then each of these are
minus KL1L2 minus KL1L2.
All of this, this is all in a
handout which will be put up
on the Stellar website.
And just so in terms of
reviewing for final and things
to go look at, for almost every
recitation we've done this
during Professor Gossard, the
other recitation instructor,
has written up the
complete problem
that was discussed
with its solution
and put it on the website.
So you don't even need to
have to copy this stuff down.
It's all posted.
In each recitation,
we've essentially
done the problem that is
sort of the objective lesson
for the week.
So they're a good
place to go review.
So this whole problem
will be up on there.
And we found a
mistake, actually.
And I think it will get
fixed before it gets put up,
but I think this
had a zero in here,
and that's actually
wrong, or if something
got transposed in writing.
That's the correct mass.
OK, so you have these numbers.
I don't want you to
work this stuff out,
because I want to focus
on the model analysis.
So let's see here.
I'm going to ask you
a question first.
So we're going to begin this.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there a torsional
damper at the top of the page?
PROFESSOR: Oh, somebody asked
a question in the last class
and I drew that up there.
But if you put a
torsional damper up there,
some CT value, how
would it appear
in the equation of motion?
Would it have L1,
L2 squareds in it?
No, it would just
simply disappear
as a plus CT theta
1 or a theta 2,
wherever it's applied
directly, theta 1 dot.
OK, so question.
Write down your piece
of paper-- so I'm not
going to make you go
to the board today,
but I want you to take a
minute and write things down.
And then we'll check and
see if everybody agrees.
The reason we can
do modal analysis
is because of something we
called the modal expansion
theorem.
It's basically the
fundamental statement
that says we can do this.
So what is the modal
expansion theorem?
You can write it
down mathematically
if you want this, just as
a little linear algebraic
expression, or you could
write it out in words.
So take 30 seconds
and write down
what makes modal analysis
work, what basic proposition.
All right, somebody help me out.
What is the modal
expansion theorem?
What's it say?
AUDIENCE: Any
motion of the system
can be described as a weighted
sum of the natural modes?
PROFESSOR: Weighted sum
of the motions of each
of the natural modes, OK.
So that's the statement,
the most succinct way
to say it is in the original
generalized coordinates,
you can express them as uq.
u is the matrix of what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, this is--
AUDIENCE: Oh no,
of the mode shapes.
PROFESSOR: Mode shapes.
And the q's are the individual
modal coordinates, right?
And so this, expanded, says
that this two degree freedom
system has two
generalized coordinates--
theta 1 and theta 2.
And the response of either
of the actual motion
of the system expressed in
the generalized coordinates
can be made up as the sum of
each of the modal coordinates,
the q sub i's,
scaled to this shape
the mode shape for that mode.
So this multiplies
the mode shape,
and that-- so everything
contributed by mode
one will move in the
shape of mode one,
and that will be
reflected in the motion
of the generalized coordinates.
And in this case,
it's a two by two.
It's a two-degree
freedom system.
Here's the mode shape
of mode 1 times q1,
which we're going to solve for,
plus the mode shape of mode two
times its model motion.
OK, that's the model
expansion theorem.
This allows you to--
in order to do this,
you have to solve
for these qi's.
So what is the
equation of motion
that governs the behavior of
each of the modal coordinates?
Write it down.
What's the whole
reason we do this?
There's one particular
equation that every one of them
satisfies.
So equation of motion,
not asking for solution.
I just want equation
of motion that
governs these modal motions.
I think I'll give you a
minute to think about it.
OK, somebody help me out.
What's the equation
of motion that I
can write that will describe
the motion of any one
of these modal coordinates, qi?
Christina?
AUDIENCE: With the
fancy M's and C's and K?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: With the
fancy M's and C's and K?
PROFESSOR: Well yeah,
but it's basically
a very simple equation
of motion, which you
should be familiar with by now.
What's it look like?
For any one of these
modal coordinates,
what is the equation of
motion that governs it?
Why do we go to
all this trouble?
There's a reason for doing this.
It's because--
AUDIENCE: Single
degree of freedom.
PROFESSOR: Ahh, the single
degree of freedom oscillator
equation, right?
This is the reason we do this.
Single degree of freedom systems
are mathematically simple.
You've seen them
since high school.
You've seen them in 1803.
It's the second order
linear differential
equation that looks like this.
And you already know
everything there
is to be known
about that equation.
And that's why one of the
reasons why we do this.
You don't have to
solve a complex set
of simultaneous
differential equations,
you just have to know one.
And so the ith one, you need
to know the ith modal mass,
the ith modal damping,
the ith modal stiffness,
and the modal force.
And we've-- in this course,
we've taught you how to solve
two kinds of single degree
of freedom system problems.
One is response to
initial conditions
when the forces on the
right hand side is zero,
and the other is
this steady state
response to a harmonic input, so
a cosine omega t kind of input.
So that's what we focused
on in this course,
because it's vibration
we're interested in.
So we've solve this equation
for two kinds of problems.
Now to do modal
analysis, you need
to be able to find
these quantities.
These we called
the modal masses,
the modal damping coefficients,
the modal stiffnesses.
How do you get those?
How, for example?
Write down on your
paper, what equation,
what linear algebra
thing do you have
to work out to get the modal
masses for this system?
Let's say all of them.
I want a two-degree system.
What's the state?
What's the mass,
the linear algebra
you have to work out to
get the modal masses?
Somebody help me.
What is it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Transpose
of the mode vector--
sorry, the mode matrix
multiplied by the mass vector?
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And then multiplied
by the mode matrix.
PROFESSOR: All right.
All right.
The modal forces
are u transpose f.
The modal masses--
and I've drawn
these little diagonal
marks in here to remind,
you these matrices
become all diagonal
when you do the model analysis.
Coordinate transformation,
I'll call it.
So the modal masses
are u transpose mu.
And this m is a matrix,
and it's the original mass
matrix of the system.
Modal stiffness,
matrix u transpose ku.
And the modal damping
matrix, u transpose cu.
But this one can be problematic.
You have to force
this one to behave.
These are guaranteed
to behave, all right?
So for this problem,
and I know some of you
are a little rusty
calculating these things.
So there's the
model mass matrix.
And here is the modal matrix
of eigenvectors or mode
shapes of the system.
u is made up of
columns, and each column
is one of the mode shapes.
The convention is to order them
from the first mode to the nth
mode where the
order is established
by the natural frequencies.
The lowest natural frequency
is first-- second, second,
up to the highest
natural frequency.
Anyway, here's mode one, here's
mode two for this system.
You have to choose
a way in which
to normalize the mode shapes.
I choose to normalize
them usually.
I say, I'm going to make
the top element of them one.
And I do that whatever--
if do MATLAB like you do,
there's a function called
Eig, which means eigenvalue.
You do Eig of A, it'll give you
the eigenvalues of matrix A.
And it'll give them back to
you unnormalized and unordered.
Well, so you can
write a little program
to put it all in nice order.
But if MATLAB gave you back
the mode shapes for a system
and it said, well, the
mode shapes of the system
are-- and it's a
two by two system.
2 and 0.4 and 0.6 0.5, you know
that the vectors are the mode
shapes, the columns.
How would you normalize those?
How would you make the top
element 1 in this first one?
AUDIENCE: Divide by 2.
PROFESSOR: Divide what by 2?
AUDIENCE: The Entire column.
PROFESSOR: The
entire column by 2.
Just factor 2 out.
So this would become
2/2 and 0.4/2.
And then that's 1 and 0.2.
So you just normalize this
vector so the top element is 1.
So do you have to normalize it?
Could you use them this way?
Sure.
But once chosen, once the
normalization is chosen,
the key to doing modal analysis
is you have to stick with it.
You can't move.
You can't mess with
that halfway through,
or you totally screw
up the solution.
So you pick your normalization.
When you calculate the natural
frequencies and mode shapes,
you pick a
normalization, and you
must ride with that
all the way through,
including putting it
back together here
at the end, this summation.
OK, so let's do-- I want
you to do this computation.
Calculate the modal
masses for this problem.
That means you have to
remember what a transpose is.
There's the model,
that's the model matrix.
And the modal mass
matrix is right there.
So actually, just
do the arithmetic.
Take a few minutes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: On the
exam, we won't have
calculators, so like is it all
going to be variables, or--?
PROFESSOR: Say that again?
AUDIENCE: On the exam, we won't
have calculators or anything.
PROFESSOR: On the exam, we'd
either make it so simple
that you can, in fact, do
it in your head or on paper,
or we won't ask a question that
you have to do it that way.
Or we'll accept an answer
where you put it down but don't
have to multiply it out.
So just do this one,
just to see if you
remember the mechanics of doing
the linear algebra to get that.
OK, somebody have
an answer for me
here for the modal mass matrix?
What's the first element?
Somebody help me.
Give me a number and then
everybody else can check you.
AUDIENCE: 0.254.
PROFESSOR: Say again?
PROFESSOR: 0.254.
OK, what about the second
one, this element over here?
Speak up.
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it better be 0.
What about this one down here?
All right, how about this one?
AUDIENCE: Wait, that
first one's not right.
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: That first
one's not right.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So did you
give me the first one?
So you're authorized
to change this.
OK, you got point what?
AUDIENCE: 859.
PROFESSOR: 8598, And this 0,
0-- how about this second one
down here now?
AUDIENCE: 3.48.
PROFESSOR: 3.48.
Anybody else get
anything different?
So let's-- we have
605 00 and 0.5,
and we're multiplying that.
So if you're looking for just
one of them, by the way--
where'd my eraser go?-- all
you need is one of the modal
masses.
The only ones that give
you non-zero results
is when you compute u transpose
for mode r m u for mode r.
So if you're only looking
for this second one,
you only have to do the
calculation for that mode.
So this then becomes a set
of matrix, matrix, matrix,
you only have to do
a couple of vectors.
So this looks like for
mode 2, it's minus what?
Mode 2 is 1, and minus 1.6949
times 0.60500 0.5 times 1
and minus 1.6949.
So to get just one
modal mass, this is M2.
To get just one modal
mass, now you only
have to do that calculation.
You only have to do
the computation using
one of the mode shapes.
So it's this times that,
and this times that
gives you some numbers back.
0.605 and half of
this about point
0.8, and then you take
that and multiply again.
Anyway, can somebody give
me this second number?
I have a 3.48.
Anybody get anything different?
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: I messed it up.
PROFESSOR: OK.
There are about 18 of you and
nobody can do this calculation?
AUDIENCE: 2.13.
PROFESSOR: Say again?
AUDIENCE: 2.130.
PROFESSOR: All right, I
have a 2.132 and a 2.0.
OK, there you are.
OK, so if you were having
trouble sorting that out,
probably a good thing to go
back and review a little bit
of your linear algebra.
OK, if you do u transpose
ku, you get this.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is it
for the [INAUDIBLE]
you have a multiplied
by F1 L1, not just F1?
PROFESSOR: OK, I'm going to
guess where I'm going next.
So to get the stiffness matrix,
u transpose ku, you get this.
We're going to leave the
damping matrix for a minute.
We need that.
We need the modal excitations.
So I'm just going to do
a particular problem.
I'm going to say,
let's let F2 be 0.
We'll only have one force.
And the first force will
be F1 cosine omega t.
And so now I need
to do u transpose
F. So here is u transpose.
Here's the F's, and
I guess I've got
to keep my cosine omega t here.
So you multiply that out.
What do you get?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why is
F1 L1 [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well,
because F1 is just
the applied force, but the
equation in motion that we're
working with, if you
go back and look at it,
what is the forces on
the right hand side?
The forces have to
be moments, right?
If we're putting a force down
there, it's a moment equation.
We need the moments
about the pivot.
So it's the force times
L1 or the force times L2.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so we don't have
to use actual magnitude of 4.
We have to use [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You have to.
You well eventually-- well,
these kind of problems
are easiest to do once you
reduce them to numbers.
I'm leaving the force in it
as a variable at the moment
just so you can see how it
carries through the problem.
But I'm just saying,
in the real problem
there, let's say there is no F2.
There is an F1, and the F1
of t looks like a magnitude
f1 times cosine omega t.
That's the only force
I have in the system.
But we're working with
equations of motions.
An equation of motion is the
right hand side-- F1, L1,
and F2 L2.
And you have to retain
the L1's and L2's in order
to have the correct
equation of motion.
So when we say this is kind
of just a generic form,
this is the modal force
vector is the mode shape
matrix times the
modal excitations
in the original coordinates.
So I just wrote F here,
but what this really means
is this is F1, L1.
F2, L2.
These are the real generalized
forces in the system.
OK, they're the real,
generalized forces.
Now, I've let F2 be 0.
So the only generalized force
is F1, L1 cosine omega T.
I multiply that by u transpose
to get-- and what do I get?
This is a pretty
simple calculation.
So this becomes F1,
L1 cos and F1, L1 cos.
So the two modal
forces are identical.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why do
we know this one
so we don't have
to include a phi?
PROFESSOR: Ah, well the
phi doesn't come out
until the answer.
What does the fee mean?
What's that phase angle mean?
If you-- remember, we're
doing steady state problems
in which F1, L1 for
example, if it's cosine,
we're just assuming
it looks like that.
And we're looking for
a solution of theta 1.
And actually, we can't
quite go there yet.
We're doing single degree
of freedom problems, right?
We are looking for
a solution for Q1.
We turn this into
a modal force, q,
but it happens to be the
capital Q1, the modal force,
is F1 L1, right?
Cosine omega t.
So that's the input.
The output is q, little q,
of t, the modal coordinate.
And what does it look like?
We're only doing steady
state, no transience.
It looks like a response
that looks like this,
but it's shifted.
I'll draw this so its
peak is right here,
cosine is its-- it's shifted
in time by this amount,
between this peak is here
versus the peak being there.
And that we can represent
as a phase angle.
Remember, one period from
here to here is 2 pi radians.
So some portion of that
period is an angle.
You can interpret it as an
angle or you can interpret it
as a time delay.
And this then has the form of
some q1 magnitude cosine omega
t minus that phase shift.
So it's only-- that's the only
thing the phase shift means.
Cosine in doesn't mean
exactly the response
out's going to be exactly in the
same perfectly in time with it.
It could be shifted.
Now you know that it--
for a single degree
of freedom system at resonance,
what's the phase angle?
Do you remember that?
It's always one number.
It's pi over 2.
A shift of pi over 2, if you
remember your trigonometry,
takes you from cosine to
sine or sine to cosine.
It's trying to tell you
that the response is
shifted by exactly a quarter
of a cycle, pi over 2.
And the reason for that
is that at resonance,
all of the excitation is going
into overpowering the damper.
And the damper's motion is
proportional to velocity.
And if velocity, if
displacement looks like cosine,
velocity looks like
one derivative of it,
which is sine.
So that pi over 2
says that the response
velocity is in phase with the
force, and that makes sense.
Something I hadn't
said in lecture
but I really meant
to is I want you
to think about something here.
Single degree of
freedom system, we'll
even write the one
we're working with.
M1 Q1 double dot plus
C1 Q1 dot plus K1 Q
equals some F1 L1
cosine omega t,
and I'm going to let
omega E be at omega 1.
But this is the equation
of motion, right?
Let's plug in.
We're saying we're going
to do this right at the--
and we know the response of this
is Q1 is some magnitude cosine
omega t minus the phasing.
We know we can plug that in.
We get minus M1 omega squared
Q1 plus K1 Q1 minus C1 omega Q1.
And this one goes like
sine omega T minus phi.
This one here needs
to get multiplied.
This term gets multiplied
by cosine omega t minus phi.
You plug that into this.
This term and this term
both behave like cosine.
This term, one derivative
behaves like minus sine.
One derivative of cosine
gives you minus sine, right?
And when omega
equals omega 1, so
when you're right at
resonance here, what happens?
This is squared.
And put the squared
down here, there we go.
So this is omega.
But now I'm going to let
it be right at omega 1.
What is omega 1 in
terms of K's and M's?
K1/M1, otherwise,
one of the checks
you can make when you finish
doing your modal-- if you take
that modal mass and
the modal stiffness
and you divide 7.96 by 0.8598,
that had better be omega 1
squared.
That's a good way
to check that you've
done all your arithmetic right.
All right, I'm going
to plug in omega 1
squared here equals K1/M1.
So I put in, this becomes
minus M1 K1 over M1, which
is minus K1, right?
Hmm, plus K1.
That resonance,
this term accounts
for the inertial force in the
system, the force required
to accelerate the mass.
This is a force equation.
This accounts for the force
required to push the spring.
The amazing thing that
happens is at resonance,
the inertial forces exactly
cancel the spring forces.
And the equation of
motion reduces to minus C1
omega 1 Q1 sine omega 1 t
minus a phase angle equals,
in this case, F1 L1
cosine omega 1 t.
So how to satisfy that equation?
What phase angle will
satisfy that equation?
Has to be pi over 2.
And if you put pi
over 2 in here,
this minus sign turns
into plus cosine.
And you're left with C1
omega 1 Q1 equals F1 L1.
So all of the exciting force
goes into pushing the dashpot.
So that's why you get the big
peak in the transfer function.
It takes in no force
to move the spring.
It takes no force to
accelerate the mass.
They exactly cancel.
And all the force is available
to drive just the dashpot,
all right?
So let's move on now.
We need to get to
our answer here.
So the last piece of this is
we now know the modal forces,
and your assignment is to
let's let omega-- let's see,
where's my-- did I
do this somewhere?
I guess not.
I guess I erased it, so we
can pick anything we want.
Let's let omega equal omega 2.
We're going to drive this
thing at the natural frequency
of the second mode.
That's the excitation.
What do you expect?
Which mode do you expect
to dominate the response?
AUDIENCE: The second.
PROFESSOR: The second mode.
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because
you are driving it.
You know it's got a transfer
function that looks like this,
and you're driving
it right here.
And where are you driving it?
If you're doing
that, where are you
on the transfer function
for the first mode?
Omega 2, it's a little higher
than omega 1, but not a lot.
So if this were the first
mode's transfer function,
where would you be driving
it on this transfer function?
If this is omega over omega 2,
you're over here a little bit.
You're driving it
a little bit higher
than the natural
frequency of mode 1.
This would be omega 2
over omega 1 on that.
So one's sitting here,
one's sitting there.
Which one's going to dominate?
The big one, OK?
Because they have
equal modal forces.
They both happen to be F1 L1.
OK, so how do you do that?
So the last step
in this thing is
I want you to, for this
case, find the first-- no,
let's do this.
Find the second
mode contribution
to the response in the original
generalized coordinates.
A quiz would often
be written this way.
It's trying to make
it easier for you.
I'm asking for only one
mode's contribution.
What does that actually mean
in the original statement
of the modal expansion theorem?
We know the total response
looks like this, right?
I'm asking you to give me only
the second mode's contribution.
What am I asking for?
Just this term.
So I'm telling
you, you don't have
to bother with the other
term to satisfy me.
Just tell me what
this one is, because I
know this is one is going
to be the dominant one.
OK, so how do I do that?
So for this problem, what
is the steady state response
of this due to mode 2 only?
So mathematically, just
in-- what's that look
like over here?
Just that second term, right?
It's the modal, mode shape
vector for mode 2 times Q2
of t.
So you need to tell me
how to find Q1 of t.
It's a single degree of freedom
problem excited by steady state
excitation.
AUDIENCE: It's like
a transfer function.
PROFESSOR: Ah, magic
word-- transfer function.
So we need the magnitude of
the-- this is a linear problem,
so the response is linearly
proportional to the--?
AUDIENCE: Force.
PROFESSOR: Force.
So the magnitude of
Q1 times a transfer
function that looks like the
hx over f transfer function.
In this case, we call it the
magnitude of HQ2 per unit Q2.
And that multiplied
by-- it looks
like cosine in this case--
omega 2 t minus some phi 2.
That's what we're looking for.
What's this?
Tell me what that looks like.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't it be Q2?
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
So in effect, what's
the transfer function?
I want it in all its detail now.
That's the magnitude
of the force.
What's in the numerator of this?
Numerator.
AUDIENCE: Well, it has
parentheses around it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's in
the denominator though.
I want just the numerator part.
This transfer
function expression
for a single degree
of freedom system,
what's in the numerator?
AUDIENCE: 1/K.
PROFESSOR: 1 over which K?
K2.
Modal K2, We're now
in the modal system.
And in the denominator of that
transfer function, what's it
look like?
AUDIENCE: 1 plus omega.
PROFESSOR: 1 minus omega
squared over-- in this case,
omega 2 squared, squared, plus--
AUDIENCE: 2 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Zeta.
AUDIENCE: Zeta, yeah.
PROFESSOR: 2.
AUDIENCE: 2 omega over
omega 2 quantity squared.
PROFESSOR: There we go.
Now in this problem,
what is omega?
So that makes this
a 2, this a 2.
This term, what happens to it?
1 minus 1.
This term, this goes to 1.
This is 2 zeta quantity
squared square root.
Just 2 zeta.
So this whole at resonance,
any one of these single degree
of freedom systems
that are at resonance,
the response is the magnitude
of the force-- in this case,
it's positive F1 L1--
over K2 times 1/2 zeta 2.
So F1 L1 is the modal magnitude
of the moral force divided
by K2 gives you what we
call the static displacement
of the system.
And this is the
dynamic application.
So oftentimes on
quizzes, you're asked
to do the response at
resonance, because it makes
all this algebra so simple.
It boils down to 1/2 zeta.
So the only thing left to do
is we need the damping ratio
for this system.
So rather than do that,
so now that, we're
missing something yet.
We're missing-- that whole thing
gets multiplied by cosine omega
2 t minus the face angel.
What's the face angel?
Pi over 2.
So Q2 of t is F1 L1 over K1
1/2-- whoops, F1 L1 over K2,
1/2 zeta 2 cosine
omega 2t minus.
And at the very--
how do we get back
to generalized coordinates,
theta 1 and theta 2?
AUDIENCE: Stay here.
PROFESSOR: Right here.
And we've computed that.
This part, you multiply
it by the mode shape.
The mode shape partitions
out the response
in the right amount
to coordinate
one and the correct
amount to coordinate two.
AUDIENCE: For the damping ratio,
would you take the modal, like,
mass and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: In
reality, what you do
with damping ratios is you're
working with real things
out there in the real world.
If you can, you go up
and give the thing a kick
and get your stopwatch out and
say, how many cycles does it
take to the k?
And is it light damping or not?
If it vibrates a lot, it's
usually light damping.
And if it's light damping, you
can force this damping matrix.
You can just make--
force it to behave,
even if it isn't perfect.
And it is a perfectly
adequate, useful answer.
Even if it isn't
perfectly diagonal,
it just doesn't matter
when it's light damping.
And so in this problem,
what you do if you go
estimate the damping
for the system.
You say eh, it looks to me
to be about 2% for mode one
and 1.5% for mode 2.
And you just say, how can I fit?
How can I represent the
damping in the system?
And one of the
easiest ones is to say
that the original damping
matrix is some alpha times
the mass matrix plus beta
times the stiffness matrix.
And in this problem-- or you
can use any part of that.
And if you're only trying
to match one mode, see,
this problem it's-- this system
is being driven at the natural
frequency of one mode.
That mode is dominating
the response, right?
So we really actually
only need a good model
of the damping for that mode.
Even if you have the
completely wrong damping
for the other mode, it will
have little effect on its answer
because you're not at resonance.
When in the transfer functions,
which look like this,
at resonance, this happens.
Then you find out that the
only force resisting the input
is the dashpot.
At low frequencies, you
find out that over here,
the dominant force is what
it takes to move the spring.
And the damping
isn't very important.
And so even if
you're wrong by 50%,
it just doesn't-- 50% of a
little bit compared to what it
takes to move the spring
is not a big deal.
And over here, it
behaves like the mass.
Out here it's called the
mass controlled region.
Over here is the stiffness
controlled region.
And in the vicinity of the
peak is the damping controlled
region.
So at low frequency,
this term dominates.
At high frequency,
that term dominates.
And at resonance, this
is the dominant term.
So in this case, let's let
the damping be some alpha
times the mass matrix.
Then when you do UTCU, you
get alpha times the modal mass
matrix.
And therefore, C2, which
is the one we care about,
is equal to alpha times M2.
And we have M2, our
modal mass, 2.04, right?
So that says this is equal-- C2
is equal to alpha times 2.04.
And if I want-- that's C2.
And how do I get zeta 2?
Zeta 2 is C2 over 2 omega 2 M2.
That's just the definition
of the damping ratio.
I know this.
So this is going to be alpha
times 2.04 over 2 omega 2 M2.
And I've measured it.
I've taken it, and
I know this is 0.02.
About 2% damping.
Solve for alpha.
You now have the whole
thing that you need.
You can now find it.
That's all you need.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Where do you get the
alphas and omegas from again?
Alphas and omegas.
PROFESSOR: This is simply--
this is called Rayleigh damping.
Lord Rayleigh 150 years
ago came up with this.
And he just said
hey, by the way,
if you model damping
this way, you
can automatically make
the equations of motion,
u transpose CU, go diagonal.
And you have a two
parameter model
with which you can juggle
them to make any two
damping ratios of the
system be exactly what you
want them to be.
So it's just-- if I left
this as alpha N beta,
then I would have worked
this problem as-- this would
have been an alpha M plus a beta
K. C2 would have been an alpha
M2.
But now it would be equal
to alpha M2 plus beta K2.
And then this still
applies, except that it'd
have this alpha and a beta.
And you could do it
for the other equation.
You could do it for zeta 1.
And you'd have two
equations and two unknowns.
You solve for alpha and beta.
But think about what
I just did here.
If I made a measurement
of the system,
I said the damping
for mode 2 is 2%.
Do I have to go
through all this junk?
No, because I know the
answer looks like that.
All I have to know is
what the damping is.
And that's my approximate
solution for the problem.
This is just how to
satisfy all the mathematics
if you want that perfect
mathematical model
for which you can write out
u transpose CU and get them.
Well, this is one
way that you force
the damper matrix to have the
properties that you want it to.
But in reality, you
just measure the damping
and put it in the answer.
Very good, this is our last
go around at recitations.
See you in class on Tuesday.
We'll do something fun that's
not covered on the final exam.
I'll give a little
review of what's
going to be on the final,
a list of what's on it.
And we'll talk about
strings and beams and things
that apply to pianos and
violins and so forth.